voilà faut-il quitter les traditions
pour entrer dans la mondialisation on
peut le résumer comme ça c'est un
dilemme africain actuel résumé à la cour
d'un village l'Afrique on en parle en
France quoi quand quand il y a une
épidémie Ébola par exemple des coups
d'état ou le terrorisme mais c'est une
autre Afrique dont on va parler ce soir
certains disent même c'est le continent
de l'avenir est-ce qu'on a le droit d'y
croire c'est une des questions qu'on va
se poser est-ce qu'on peut se développer
au rythme des coups d'état qu'est-ce
qu'il faut dire de la corruption par
exemple que faut-il abandonner les
traditions la culture ça se disait
beaucoup dans le film bref à quel prix
l'Afrique peut-elle rejoindre l'Asie la
Chine l'Inde aurant des puissances
émergentes voilà les questions qu'on va
se poser ce soir avec la réalisatrice
coréalisatrice et co-auteur de ce film
chloéch Borau bonsoir à vous bonsoir
vous signez ce film avec Vincent Schmit
et Claude le terrier avec également
l'écrivain Antoine Glazer journaliste
fondateur de la Lettre du Continent vous
venez de publier Africa France vous avez
inverscer les mots hein c'est
France-Afrique jusque là donc
visiblement tout bouge c'est publié chez
Fayard l'ancien ambassadeur pierre
chercheur associé à l'Institut des
relations internationales et
stratégiques Liris et enfin Henry
Bernard Solignac le compte économiste à
l'OCDE c'est vous notamment qui mesurez
chaque année les performances des
différents pays africains alors est-ce
qu'il y a un miracle ou un mirage
économique africain ce sera évidemment
une question Chloé et chaboro d'abord je
voudrais que vous m'expliquiez comment
vous avez fait comment vous avez fait
pour vous faire accepter comme ça faire
accepter une caméra dans la cour de
cette microociété qui est une cour
familiale de village bah il faut bah
d'abord on n'est pas arrivé avec une
caméra et il faut savoir que moi je suis
issu aussi d'une cour comme celle qu'on
voit dans le film j'ai grandi comme ces
enfants qu'on voit évoluer et en Afrique
euh toutes les raisons sont bonnes pour
pour être ensemble pour être de la même
famille donc le film se passe dans la
2uxè ville du Burkina il y a plus d'un
million d'habitants quand même et on est
rentré dans une bonne vingtaine de cours
avant d'en choisir une où on allait
rester s'installer d' choisir une ou
d'être accepté par par une on a
généralement été accepté presque par
toutes les cours parce que justement
quand on arrivait quand je me présentais
je disais mon notre famille alors il y
avait toujours quelqu'un qui disait ah
mon ancien voisin était marié ou a était
ami avec quelqu'un qui vient de tel
village donc tu es notre enfant tu peux
entrer on nous servait à manger on était
chez nous donc vous avez travaillé en
famille une certain manière c'est une
famille très élargie mais à l'africaine
je peux me permettre de dire comme ça
c'est ça c'est ça à l'africaine
justement comme on dit la famille c'est
manches longuees et euh toutes les
raisons sont bonnes pour être de la même
famille et il y a toutes les cours on
est rentré j'étais chez moi tout tout
simplement donc on est rentré on a on
est resté avec les gens pendant un bon
moment avant de sortir les caméras en
fait et euh vous avez fait parler si
facilement que ça les gens de polygamie
par exemple ah non par contre rentrer
c'est une chose les faire parler c'est
autre chose on est accepté on partage le
repas d'ailleurs si vous partagez pas le
repas c'est que voilà vous vous vous
voulez vous voulez pas être avec eux
donc on partage le repas on est ensemble
mais faire dire les choses des choses
aussi intimistes qu'on peut entendre
dans le film ça c'est autre chose et ça
ça se
travaille sur le long terme sur 2 ans
c'est ça une année et demi d'immersion
dans la cour on a été un an et demi dans
la cour parce qu'il y a des choses tout
à fait étonnantes quand même dans le
documentaire qu'on vient de voir sur la
manière dont les comment on dit cemmes
coépouses les coépouses les coépouse se
parl l'une de l'autre c'est c'est chargé
parfois hein ah c'est trs char c'est un
tout petit univ avec autant de tension
pression de parfois d'animosité beaucoup
d'animosité mais c'est normal les hommes
essayent de faire croire que la
polygamie c'est accepté que les femmes
voilà c'est il y a pas de jalousie mais
il y a des jalousies mais les codes
sociaux demandent à ce que ces jalousie
soit cachée on les montre pas le le
savoir vivre ensemble c'est aussi faire
semblant de d'aimer tout le monde d'être
bien avec tout le monde et puis en
dessous on n'est pas forcément bien avec
tout le monde je suis frappé bon votre
liberté de parole je la comprends vous
venez d'écrire ce film mais par la
liberté de parole des femmes en général
dans votre film justement c'est quand on
était on a vu aussi les grains de thé
dans le film et dans les grains ils nous
disent les grains de thé c'est le c'est
ce que certains appelleraient l'arbre à
palabre si on est dans la caricature
africaine mais c'est pas une caricature
c'est une réalité alors c'est un oui
c'est c'est c'est un endroit où on se
retrouve alors en général tout le monde
appartient à un grain de thé hein moins
les femmes que les hommes mais tout le
monde appartient à un grain thé on se
retrouve et puis c'est c'est
pratiquement le seul endroit où on on
peut dire tout sans tabou on peut parler
de tout sans se soucier que l'autre est
plus âgé que de ne pas vexer quelqu'un
parce que c'est quand même des sociétés
du silence on peut pas parler comme ça
et dans les graines de thé on peut
parler de tout et on entend dans les
graines de thé ils disent que ils disent
les autres ils croient que la femme
africaine c'est une femme soumise qui a
pas droit à la parole mais c'est faux
ils disent le proverbe africain le
proverbe qui dit euh la nuit porte
conseil bah ça vient de chez nous parce
que la nuit elle vient pas te voir pour
te porter conseil parce que les les
codes sociaux demandent à ce que l'homme
garde toujours la tête haute et la femme
elle doit toujours faire semblant d'être
en c'est la nuit qu'elle recadre son
mari c'est dire c'estàdire que l'homme
il prend jamais de décisions sans
concerter sa femme donc en appar la
femme qui porte conseil c'est pas la
nuit ça mais c'est la nuit qu'on trouve
sa femme voilà en apparence on a
l'impression que les femmes n'ont pas
droit à la parole que les femmes ne
disent jamais rien mais au fond ell
parle beaucoup et quand elles ont des
choses à dire elles le disent vraiment
et on on les entend votre film et
franchement c'est exceptionnel qu'est-ce
que vous vouliez dire finalement qu'il
faut quitter farafinko cette cour pour
entrer dans le grand monde qu'il est
temps de changer que l'Afrique doit
changer quel est le message que vous
portez alors je sais pas il y a pas
forcément une prétention de dire ce
qu'il faut faire ou ce qu'il ne faut pas
faire je pense pas que ce soit
d'ailleurs le l'approche d'un film
documentaire pour moi c'était on avait
envie de montrer une réalité c'est une
immersion dans une cour dans une cour
mendingue une cour ouest africaine parce
que alors d'abord comment est né ce
projet c'est que comme je le disais moi
je suis issue d'une famille comme ça
d'une cour comme ça et euh à un moment
donné de ma vie j'avais beaucoup de
questions j'avais beaucoup de
questionnements comme une forme de
tiraillement existentiel parce que
j'entendais beaucoup dire que ce soit
les médias à l'école les enseignants les
leaders d'opinion j'entendais beaucoup
dire oui la situation de l'Afrique c'est
c'est la faute des autres c'est
l'histoire c'est la traite c'est la
colonisation on l'entend d'Urs oui voilà
mais personne ne ne nous disait jamais
nulle part où était notre part de
responsabilité personnellement moi je
trouvais que dans dans ma culture il y a
des choses qui étaient bien qui étaient
super bien mais je trouvais aussi qu'il
y avait des choses qui étaient à revoir
mais je me sentais seule avec ce
sentiment là et j'avais j'avais envie
d'entendre quelqu'un parler de ça parler
de la part de responsabilité des
Africains dans la situation de l'Afrique
et puis j'ai fait une lecture j'ai
croisé un ouvrage à un moment donné
j'étais avec mon mon Marie Claude
leerrier qui est co-auteur de ce film
c'était l'ouvrage et si l'Afrique
refusait le développement d'Axelle Cabou
qui elle osait mettre le doigt sur
certains problèmes de l'Afrique mais
aussi surtout sur la part de
responsabilité des Africains qu'est-ce
qui ne va pas dans notre culture
qu'est-ce qui fait que on bloque et
qu'on ararrive pas à aller de l'avant
alors qu'on a un continent quand même
qui est très riche on a un sous-sol qui
est riche faut dire ce qui est on très
intéressant on a un sous-sol qui est
très riche culturellement bouger
finalement vous dites bouger
bougeons-nous bah déjà bougez-vous quoi
regarder et dire bon il y a quand même
des choses qui vont pas aussi chez nous
les autres les autres sont pas des anges
mais nous on n'est pas non plus que des
victimes en tout cas pas des victimes
innocentes quoi pas que des victimes
innocentes donc moi j'avais envie de que
quelqu'un parle de ça et quand j'ai lu
cet ouvrage là j'ai eu envie d'en parler
aussi et c'est comme ça un peu qu' né
ces films là qu'est-ce que vous en avez
pensé les uns et les autres Antoine
glazard très franchement je trouve que
ce la tradition quandme ce documentaire
devrait être diffusé dans dans les
écoles en France parce que pour
comprendre
moi ce que j'ai bien aimé justement
c'est qu'il y ait pas de jugement de
valeur je veux dire est-ce que c'est
bien c'est mal c'est vraiment de montrer
qu'est-ce qui se passe réellement en
Afrique et moi j'ai toujours du mal même
à des confrères à leur expliquer comment
la gestion comment un Africain comment
il peut il arrive il doit gérer sa vie
avec sa famille comment ça c'est c'est
dit à plusieurs fois c'est dire la
fierté c'est notre famille même si à
Moné il dit oui avoir 10 personnes sur
ses sur ses ailes on risque de tomber mê
person j'ai souvent j'explique des
confrères explique ce qu'on retrouve un
peu dans le film en disant imaginez que
le matin vous sortez et vous devez
dialoguer à votre votre grand-père qui
est enterré dans le jardin et que
finalement si vous voyez à mon quelque
chose qui bouge dans la cour ou autre
vous allez voir il m'indique si m'a dit
que ça ça veut dire cette cette
pesanteur ce dialogue aussi avec cet
univers surnaturel le dialogue avec avec
les ancêtres comment pour un Africain
toutes ces pesanteurs comment c'est
voilà c'est ça c'est ça l'Afrique et je
trouve que là je trouve c'est vraiment
bien jeux dire montrer et je trouve pas
justement il il y a justement pas cette
idée il faut que l'Afrique elle sorte de
la grande cour faut que faut qu'elle
sorte de ses traditions faut qu'elle
aille vers la modernité l'idée que
l'homme africain n'est pas entré dans
l'histoire célèbre discours de Nicol
gros pom je trouve que Alassan qui qui
explique dans le film qui est l'homme
qui explique voilà je je ne peux pas on
vient me voir j'ai j'ai pas d'argent
mais c'est pas possible de ne pas donner
cette solidarité africaine de faire
comprendre ça ce qu'il va donner quand
même oui mais bon il vient il donne mais
c'est extrêmement
important en France en particulier enfin
en Europe en général mais en France en
particulier on veut tellement que les
Africains nous ressemblent on aime que
les Africains qui sont à notre image on
a beaucoup de mal à accepter l'Afrique
et les africains tels qu'ils sont du
coup ça nous empêche de connaître de
savoir et je pense que ce documentaire
apporte énormément sur ce planl il
permet voilà ça l'Afrique c'est comme ça
avec que vous aimz que que vous l'aimiez
vous l'z pas elle est comme ça
en tout cas une partie pour partie parce
que visiblement ça bouge on va discuter
évidemment avec les les deux autres
invités ça sent lorsque Alassan qui est
donc mécanicien qui dit lui-même qu'il
est le seul à nourrir tout le monde ici
donc le seul à travailler qui est aussi
le gardien des traditions d'une certaine
manière il le revendique comme ça
lorsqualassan donc regarde le monde
changer autour de
lui de NS jours c'est la manière de VI
de tout c'est maintenant
l'argent que quelquun a un peu il faut
qu'il le
montre si chacun doit partir de la cour
il ne restera plus qu'à la vendre et se
partager l'argent la cour n'exister plus
richendeter et imble et
sera devant en disant là c'était notre
cours familiale des exemples comme ça il
y en a plein même dans le
quartier dans les nouvelles
constructions modernes chacun s'orte
bien fermé pour accéder il faut appuyer
sur un bouton te faire entendre et quand
il n'y a pas de sonnerie c'est un chien
qui est là et qui te chasse quand tu
essayes d'entrer c'est ça la nouvelle
norme pierjacqu c'est ça la
nouvellearique oui moi je vois c ce film
comm un théâtre un espace clot euh où il
y a un univers qui est fortement marqué
au départ une une évolution pendant
pendant toute
cette comme dans une pièce de théâtre
donc il y a un espace clos qui est
fortement marqué par le le système rural
le système paysan la famille ligagère et
puis qui sous le coup de l'extérieur
subit toute une série de modifications
euh et et tant d'y répondre tant bien
que mal alors il y a le phénomène de
l'argent qui vient bousculer bouer les
les les la solidarité à l'intérieur du
du du groupe de la
famille parce que on ne peut plus
satisfaire à tous ces besoins toutes ces
sollicitations à ce qu'on appelle
quelquefois l'impérialisme de la famille
qui fait qu'onimpérialisme de la famille
de la famille oui j'ai vécu j'ai vécu
longtemps au Burkina c'est une
expression qu'on entendait en tout cas à
wagadouou cette espèce de pression
permanente qui qui pèse sur celui qui a
un revenu ça vaut aussi donc pour les
africains qui ont quitté le africain qui
vivent vous vous avez le même phénomène
vis-à-vis des du migrant qui il a du
travail ou il a pas du travail et
sollicité en permanence c'est à ce
devoir de pouvoir envoyer alors qu'il a
fait voilà il faut comprendre que les
Africains qui vivent par exemple en
France ils sont sous votre contrôle
combien
650000 étrangers c'est ça venu
s'installer en africain venu s'installer
en France il faut comprendre qu'il sont
sollicité de la même manière ou al voir
leur disant ça va pas je m'en sors pas
il faut m'aider alors que certain sont
parti sont partis pas tous mais certains
sont partis précisément pour
s'affranchir contre cette contre cet
impérialisme qui en permanence le
rattrape mais on entend très bien dans
ce que dit Alassan c'est que on
s'émancipe de plus en plus de cette
contrainte et celui qui a un revenu
après tout il ronacle de plus en plus à
pouvoir satisfaire cette sollicitation
multiples qui est celle de la petite
nièce qui débarque du village et qui
vient encore accroître le le l'espace
l'autre phénomène l'autre bouleversement
c'est évidemment celui des femmes dont
on on a dont on a parlé parler un peu
plus tard mais mais qui me paraît
intéressant dans la mesure où là aussi
il y a une du fait du contact avec la
ville du fait que ces femmes ne sont
plus à donner au travail agricole ou à
certaines corvées parce que l'eau
potable est peut-être là à disposition
peut-être parce qu'elles ont un travail
ù elles dégagent leur propre revenus
elles ont un droit de parole beaucoup
plus important le jour pas seulement la
nuit pour pouvoir se repositionner et
avec beaucoup de avec beaucoup d'humour
mais avec un esprit un peu sournoir
parler de leur mari une vraie tonicité
hein ça ça envoie le bois comme on dit
chez nous allez-y oui alors c'est pas
juste celui qui prend tout le monde en
charge qui travaille hein les autres
peuvent travailler aussi la preuve c'est
que dans la cour Ibrahim il travaille et
je pense qu'il gagne bien mieux sa vie
qu'alassan finalement mais c'est quand
même Alassan qui distribue l'argent
parce que c'est le droit desess parce
que Alassan c'est le né en tout cas dans
donc le salaire d'Ibrahim vient chez
Alassan non du tout Ibrahim il garde son
salaire pour lui c'est pour ça c'est
c'est mologie finalementut c'est mologie
il n a pas besoin d'exercer la
solidarité il est pas le chef de la Cour
bah si si vous voulez c'est à la base on
a un champ on a un champ familial et
tout le monde cultive dedans et c'est
l'îné qui va gérer et redistribuer à
tout le monde là on est dans un système
qui s'est modernisé tout le monde
travaille de son côté a son salaire les
plus jeunes devraient ramener leur
revenus dans le on va dire dans le
panier commun mais ils vont pas ramener
mais le grand frère lui il ne peut pas
faillir il est obligé de continuer de
faire M tout le monde de payer les
factures c'est voilà c'est donc donc
tout a bougé en vérité sous l'apparence
d'une cour qui n'a pas changé tout a
changé et en profondeur l'économie
africaine a changé de la même manière
j'ai lu une statistique je voudrais vous
la soumettre Henry Bernard solinac le
compte parce que 53 % des Africains
seulement on lot courante 93 % ont un
portable oui et là ce qui est très
intéressant dans le reportage pour
l'économiste c'est qu'on on voit bien
des tensions entre diverses phénomènes
qui qui ont lieu et que souvent nous ici
on confond il y a trois choses la
première chose c'est la modernisation
c'est-à-dire que cette Afrique qu'on
voit dans le documentaire n'a rien à
voir avec celle du début du siècle n'a
rien à voir avec celle des indépendances
c'est déjà une génération complètement
différente les les représentations
changent les rapports entre les gens
dans la cour entre hommes et femmes
changeent les l'ouverture à la
mondialisation on a un parent tout ce
qui est en France ou peut-être aux
États-Unis ou ailleurs en Afrique qui
qui renvoie de l'argent l'État ne joue
plus le même rôle que celui qui jouait
après la au terme de la la
décolonisation
on a des des des figures tutellaaires
qui tout à coup sont tombé de leur
pieddestal et on se cherche de de
nouvelles de nouveaux leaders donc il y
a une vraie modernisation c'est une
transformation en profondeur des
habitudes des modes de vie vous parlez
des téléphone portabl par exemple donc
cette Afrique change très vite ça c'est
la première chose la deuxième chose on
parle de l'argent he effectivement un
promoteur risque de venir d'acheter la
cour de construire un immeuble parce que
vous le rappeliez en début d'émission il
y a eu plus de 10 % de croissance
pendant pardon plus de 5 % de croissance
par an pendant les 10 dernières années
en Afrique ça veut dire on aimerait bien
ça veut dire une accumulation de
richesse considérable mais qui n'est pas
bien partagée donc ça c'est aussi un
foyer de tension et troisième chose
c'est enfin le le le problème du
développement c'est que cette
modernisation cette croissance elles
sont possibles sans que pour autant la
qualité de vie le niveau de vie des gens
leur espérance de vie la la la la
mortalité infantile ne connaissent la
même évolution positive donc on a trois
phénomènes modernisation croissance et
développement qui vont pas dans le M
même sens et on sent ces tensions quand
on voit les jeunes par exemple qui se
demandent de quoi sera fait leur avenir
et opportun vouses en train de décrire
non mon l'ambassadeur c'est des
flagrants comme comme cocktail quand
quand tout d'un coup il y a un mieux qui
arrive et qu' n'est pas partagé et qu'
les fruits où les gouttes ne
redescendent pas jusque jusqu'au SOC
c'est comme ça que naissent les
révolutions non oui mais vous avez
raison simplement ça heurte notre
imaginaire d'occidental où le
développement c'est quelque chose de de
linéaire avec cet effet de rusellement
qui Béné iici à tous et qui ne souffre
pas de résistance forte c'est pas le cas
le Burkina par exemple vient d'annoncer
le le nouveau gouvernement parce qu'il y
a eu un coup d'État au Burkina ou plus
exactement un changement le Président
sortant est parti vient d'annoncer que
finalement on voyer à la baisse les
prévisions de croissance ce ne serait
que 5,1 % et cette croissance là oui
mais pas elle ne ruisselle pas elle est
elle est tout à fait d'abord tout à fait
abstraite vous dites à un membre de la
Cour qu'il y a un taux de croissance de
5 % pour lui ça n'a strictement aucune
signification oui mais même pour un
Français honnêtement les taux croissant
sous de PIB ça n'a pas de sens mais
quand même ce qu'on vit au quotidien ça
ça a un sens si ça n'est pas partagé ça
se voit oui mais vous avez évoqué les
événements récents du Burkina Faso si
précisément il y a eu un un refus d'une
reconduction d'un chef d'État installé
depuis 27 ans c'est probablement parce
que il y a des des changements dans dans
des mentalités profondes et que les
figures tutellaaires que vous évoquz
tout à l'heure prennent un sérieux un
sérieux coup derrière la tête et que ces
bouleversements qu'on appelle nous
développement parce qu'on ne sait pas
les appeler autrement sont en fait des
mutations profondes dans la conception
que peuvent avoir pas seulement les
jeunes mais les femmes aussi sur ce qui
est bon pour eux ce qui est euh ce qui
est bon pour leur l'amélioration de
leurs conditions d'existence au-delà des
taux de croissance qui sont encore une
fois des abstractions c'est c'est la
grande difficulté d'expliquer euh
comment dit le tout ce qui se passe sur
ce continent d'abord l'Afrique n'est pas
un pays ça paraît bête mais il faut dire
que l'Afrique c'est depu tout à l'heure
je dis l'ariqueoui mais on dit parce que
vraiment c'est très difficile ça veut
dire de dire à la fois que c'est tous
les paradoxes ça va être le continent de
des inégalités ça va être le continent
où il y aura le plus d'inégalités parce
pourquoi parce que vous allez avoir vous
allez vous allez passer de 1 milliard à
2 milliards d'habitants en 2050 2
milliards d'habitants vous avez des pays
comme le Nigéria vous avez 170 millions
d'habitants vous en aurez 340 400
millions j'adore dire qu'il y aura plus
de Nigériens sur terre que d'Amérique
les gens ça ça les effra mais il faut
comprendre il faut ça frappe mais il
faut comprendre qu'à la fois si vous
passez de 1 à 2 milliards vous aurez
vous aurez sans doute 1,7 milliards de
gens pauvres encore extrêmement pauvres
mais vous aurez 300 millions de
consommateurs et si on dit que c'est le
continent de demain pourquoi tout le
monde pourquoi chinois les trucs les
gens sont là parce que c'est un
continent avec une démographie qui qui
est vraiment explosive et c'est un
continent avec ses aspects positifs ASP
nétif et continents de tous les
paradoxes de toutes les inégalités et ça
va être extrêmement difficile de parler
de ce continent quand vous êtes un
observateur un journaliste ou un
chercheur sans à chaque fois vous êtes
obligé de à chaque fois de prendre la
loupe et d'expliquer le Burkina Faso n'a
rien à voir avec le Nigéria l'ensemble
des pays d'Afrique de l'Ouest
francophones des anciennes colonies
françaises représentent même pas
finalement le le pb de le Nigéria c'est
en même temps les gens ils entendent
beaucoup Aram avec ce qui se passe
absolument ouventable Nord
nigéa et en même temps vous avez c'est
le Nigéria c'est la plus grande
puissance économique du contintinent qui
est passé devant l'Afrique du Sud avec
500 milliards de dollars vous voyez le
le paradoxe mais vous avez dit 300
millions de consommateurs ça veut dire
une classe moyenne c'est ça qu'on dit
généralement l'économie quand tout d'un
coup il y a des consommateurs c'est
qu'on a une classe moyenne une classe
moy afriain la classe moyenne c'est que
c'est c'est un concept qui est difficile
à manipuler d'abord c'est pas seulement
un seuil statistique he c'est un concept
dans dans je dirais la littérature
économique et sociale européenne qui
aussi politique là aujourd'hui on a
effectivement un nombre croissant de
gens qui tout à coup gagnent plus que ce
qu'il faut pour juste survivre est-ce
que ça ça fait une classe moyenne est-ce
qu'avec 2,5 dollars par jour au lieu de
2 dollars est-ce qu'on devient à
quelqu'un de la classe moyenne je pense
qu'il faut faut faut peut-êreaciser un
petit peu il faut dire j'ai entendu j'ai
entendu pas citer une grande compagnie
française de
télécommunication ce matin sur Radio
France International qui expliquait en
disant c'est formidable il y a on a 100
millions d'abonnés maintenant sur le
continent AF africain l'Égypte pour nous
représente plus que la France la France
seule donc on revient aussi les gens
n'ont pas électricité ils ont pas l'eau
mais ils ont le le téléphone et le type
il alors là c'est c'est l'explosion ça
veut dire c'est c'est ça aussi ce ce
paradoxe ça veut dire il y a quand même
suffisamment de gens qui ont un un
portable chin c'est que avant on avait
l'Afrique qui était un gigantesque
réservoir de matières premières hein en
gros dans lequel tout le monde vit elle
est toujours ce qui est nouveau c'est
que maintenant elle est aussi un marché
hein 1 milliard de consommateurs
officiellement depuis depuis
CR
et achète mais on produit pas on produit
encore très peu on produit très peu une
des questions que pose votre film je
voudrais qu'on en parle avec vous
maintenant Chloé Aich Bor c'est la
question de savoir qui en profite et
comment on l'a déjà un peu évoqué
d'ailleurs on est au moment du du thé du
grain de thé comme vous l'appelez
joliment comme ça s'appelle joliment
d'ailleurs un homme dit finalement si on
n profite pas c'est à cause des blancs
et là une femme prend la vous l'avez vu
dans le documentaire tout à l'heure elle
lui répond en substance au lieu de
chercher des coupabl prends-toi en main
moi je veux dire làhaut moi je veux
qu'on arrête de dire l'esclavage tant en
ce qui est passé est passé c'est vrai le
passé là quand on parle de Burkina ingre
là qu on parle de comment on appelle ça
les que émergent à l'horizon 2020 là on
peut pas parler du développement sans
parler de la jeunesse nous sommes le
développement nous sommes la venue du
pays à nous de dé
qu'est-ce que on veut pour
l'arique'est-ce on veut pour notre pays
c'est à nous de parler on a des diplômes
on a qu' arrêé de dire le passé le passé
le passé c'est le
Pass pass le
passvelo on peut se développer il y a
pas de
Fire ça chauffe Chloé Chab on est encore
une fois très frappé de voir que c'est
une femme qui vient remettre les hommes
à leur place ou plus exactement essayer
de les faire bouger bah oui et puis pour
venir sur ce qu'elle dit c'est vrai que
les Africains ont enfin les Africains
encore une fois l'Afrique c'est c'est
plusieursou ouais c'est on peut pas
synthétiser euh toute l'Afrique voilà
c'est mais en tout cas en parlant
d'Afrique de l'Ouest parce qu'il y a
quand même quelques constantes qui font
que voilà tout n'est pas pareil mais il
y a des constantes qui font qu'on peut
parler de de l'Afrique de l'Ouest ou au
moins du Burkina c'est vrai que on a
encore beaucoup en tête la traite la
colonisation et ça revient et puis on
nous permet pas d'oublier aussi encore
une fois comme je disais soit les
leaders d'opinion les médias tout ça
mais à côté de ça il y a aussi ceux qui
disent mais c'est bon quoi il faut
arrêter il y a de l'eau qui a coulé sous
les P dit on a des diplômes donc il y a
une école une université qui produit des
diplômés des gens qui savent faire qui
savent et qui savent faire s oui mais on
n pas toujours les bons dirigeants mais
surtout on n pas toujours les bonnes
mentalités parce que on nous dit qu'on a
pas les bons dirigeants mais tu enlèves
un dirigeant et tu mets un autre il fait
pareil on vient d'enlever blise compauré
au Burkina qu'est-ce que qui nous dit
que celui qui va venir il va pas faire
pareil il y a beaucoup plus de chance
qu'il fasse pareil qu'autre chose de
toute façon c'est une méfiance qui est
partagée chez nous aussi hein ça c'est
pas burkinabé hein ni même africain
cette méfiance vis-à-vis des des de la
classe politique d'une manière générale
mais moi je suis frappé de voir que les
femmes prennent la parole 1 et je
voudrais vous poser la question de
savoir si pour vous les femmes sont des
moteurs de développement ah oui beaucoup
ah oui beaucoup surtout dans notre
culture où justement c'est les femmes
qui se lève à 4h du matin c'est pas les
hommes hein on travaille beaucoup plus
que les hommes parce que il faut bah en
Afrique traditionnelle c'est simple le
il y a le champ du mari et chaque femme
a son champ et chaque femme va
travailler dans le champ du mari et
travailler dans son propre champ c'est
un peu ça qui est chacun a son champ oui
et c'est ça qui est qui est re qui est
retranscrit on va dire dans dans
l'Afrique moderne aujourd'hui la femme
c'est-à-dire que la femme il faut
qu' elle assume toutes les tâches à la
maison les tâches ménagères les bébés
tout ça mais il faut aussi qu'elle
ramène maintenant quelque chose à la
maison elle ne peut plus se contenter de
rester à la maison et attendre que
l'homme aille tout chercher et ramener
donc elle a elle a les deux poids il
faut qu'elle assume à la maison mais
qu'elle sorte aussi et qu'elle ramène on
dit on dit l'Afrique c'est c'est pas
l'Europe faut pas faut pas comparer
enfin là encore il y a un certain nombre
de femmes européennes qui diront c'est
un peu pareil pour moi c'est-à-dire que
moi je fais aussi tous les boulots à la
maison je l'entends je l'entends souvent
heinend et pas à la maison parce que
vous imaginez bien que je suis un mari
modèle mais c'est c'est pas le cas Mama
ben sont les femmes d'affaires c'est ça
c'est ces femmes ces femmes leaders
économi ou et j'ai noté aussi parce qu'
elles avaient des fois expliqué elles
avaient des Mercedes c'était les plus
riches
réusss qui tend à disparaître MAM ben on
a fait un travail avecf l'Université de
Bordeaux qui a beaucoup travaillé sur
les classes moyennes euh observe que la
concurrence exercée en particulier par
les Chinois fait que ce type de commerce
qui était très florissant dans les
années 80 a sérieusement pris un un
sérieux prix un coup sur la tête donc
qui aujourd'hui économiquement dirige la
Afrique ou en tout cas fait profit de
l'Afrique du chinois en partie en partie
les systèmes économiques et politiques
d'ailleurs africains he je P son les
Français c'est ça que je veux dire par
exemple c'est ce sont des systèmes qui
sont extravertis hein depuis la la
l'indépendance de des économies des pays
africains on a eu des systèmes dans
lesquels il y avait pas d'autosuffisance
on peut pas exploiter par exemple les
ressources en pétrole avec des
technologies ave des capitaux qui sont
essentiellement africains sauf peut-être
en Afrique du Sud au Maroc mais dans la
plupart des pays on a besoin je dirais
par de manière structurelle des autres
pour exploiter ses propres richesses
donc ça aussi c'est c'est un petit peu
ce qui transparaît dans le reportage
c'est que cette extraversion en fait
elle est un trait caractéristique de ces
de ces économies africaines et
aujourd'hui ce qui tirent les bénéfices
de ces ressources ce sont ben d'abord
les élites qui parce qu'il contrôlent le
pouvoir politique ont accès à la rente
la rente du pétrole la rente de l'or par
exemple ou d'autres une corruption
importante en Afrique aujourd'hui mais
partout dans le monde he il y a pas il y
a pas qu'en Afrique la grande différence
c'est que dans les pays asiatiques où
beaucoup de corruption il y a a eu
beaucoup de croissance et pas mal de
redistribution sous la forme de création
d'emploi ça dans la majorité des
économies africaines c'est ce quient
c'est qu'on on voit pas cette création
d'emploi dans le secteur formel dans les
pays d'Afrique subsaharienne vous avez
environ 7 % des jeunes qui ont ce que
vous et moi on appellerait un emploi
décent les autres ont soit pas d'emploi
soit un emploi pas payé travaille dans
le secteur informel ou attendre sur les
bans de l'école un EMP qui secteur
informel c'est quoi c'est on travaille
au noir on travaille comme c'est oui
c'est c'est l'économie qui n'est pas
régulée je dirais qui est qui qui est de
les gens qui vendent des cigarettes dans
la rue ou les petits méti secteur
informel a aussi un secteur extrêmement
dynamique dans le secteur informel c'est
le monde de la création de l'ingéniosité
de la débrouille mais pas au sens
péjoratif c'est pas uniquement le le
travail sousterrain au noir au sens
négatif c'est en fait du point de vue
statistique c'est le travail qui n'est
pas enregistré qui n'est pas
comptabilisé qui n'est pas fiscalisé
mais ça ve pas dire grand chose une fois
que vous avez dit ça ça cache énormément
d'activités les investisseurs étrangers
j'ai d que c'était 60 milliards d'euros
l'an dernier ouais et ça va continuer à
augmenter là c'est énorme ça a un peu
baissé au moment de notre crise c'est
autant que l'aide internationale autant
que les revenus rapatriés par les
migrants mais ça c'est nouveau au cours
de la décennie écoulée parce que ça veut
dire que l'Afrique est redevenue une
terre de profit et plus seulement un
endroit où on donne de l'aide pour aider
les pauvres et les sociétés françaises
les entreprises française participe
encore à ces investissements ou de moins
en moins oui alors il y a des secteurs
il y a des secteurs comme le bâtimement
et travaux publics où c'est ça devient
très compliqué parce que évidemment
c'est c'est un paradoxe incroyable ça
veut dire enfin là je vais faire court
mais au moment où finalement les pays
occidentaux annulai les dettes des États
africains vous avez un autre grand frère
qui s'appelle la Chine qui arrive et qui
dit aux États africains voilà vous avez
pas d'argent c'est pas grave moi je
prends tout en charge et tout je vais
vous faire des superp infrastructures et
autres mais donnez-moi vos matières
premières en échange ça veut dire on he
ou Vau terre ou Vau terre matière
première et terre donc bien évidemment
vous avez des de des milliards de
dollars donc la France je dire la France
évidemment la France on peut pas il y
avait une période qui était particulière
qui était la période finalement de la
guerre froide de 1960 à 89 où évidemment
les Français étaient dans un espace
protégé donc les entreprises françaises
qui avaient quasiment aucun appel d'
vous appeliez le Président vous aviez
immédiatement le contrat bah cette
période est révolue ça veut dire il y a
une concurrence absolument incroyable
moi je suis surpris comment finalement
on a l'air de découvrir l'état de
rapport qui de de Sénat et autres qui
disent oh là là on n' pas vu les
puissance France émergente arrivé la
France est tellement cru que les Chinois
finalement auraient besoin de la France
même pour dialoguer avec l'Afrique que
voilà bien sûr que la France ça sa part
s réduite passé environ de 11 à 5 %
actuellement sur les marchés mais en
même temps est-ce que c'était normal que
au Gabon on a vu 50 % des des des
marchés en Côte d'Ivoire c'était 30 17 %
si on a remplacé un impérialisme si j'
dire pardon un impérialisme français par
un impérialisme chinois est-ce que
est-ce que l'Afrique a gagné alors les
Africains ils aiment pas que les les
Français critiquent les chinois ils ont
dit vous avez fait personne justement
les Africains ils ont toujours en tête
même si la part de de l'Occident diminu
et que c'est les Chinois qui prennent
plus de place dans la tête des Africains
c'est c'est simple he si il y a pas le
l'uranium du Niger bah la France a pas
d'électricité s'il y a pas le Colan du
Congo s'il y a pas le coton du Mali et
du
Burkina voilà s'il y a pas le café cacao
donc on est vraiment resté dans le
ressenti de de la colonisation de Dublin
qui vient piller et on se rend rend pas
compte et c'est comme si on voyait pas
le chinois alors que comme dit je sais
plus qui le disait la France était avec
la carotte mais les Chinois c'est avec
le le fou et quand on va se réveiller se
rendre compte que les chinois c'est pire
ça va être dur quoi la tentation en
attendant pour certains c'est partir on
le voit aussi dans votre documentaire
alors à la ville pour certains mais là
on est déjà dans une ville en ce qui
concerne la cour que vous avez choisi la
cour familiale pour d'autres c'est la
direction de l'Europe l'Europe les
blancs le rêve du frère d'alassan ah
c'est ça et il le dit assez crument ma
deè femme ça sera une blanche va aller
vivre là avec elle 6 mois 7 mois je
viens mois de décembre comme ça novembre
décembre je viens
[Musique]
ici voir la deè
elle aura droit ou comme ça quel qu'en
soit ALP il y en a qui vont rester
d'autres vont
partir
[Musique]
moi ce que je sais moi je veis pas
rester
ici ça jamais de la
vie
jamais l'Afrique c'est 75% de de jeunes
gens hein c'est à peu près ça la
population africaine5 65% de jeunes gens
ils ont tous dans la tête l'idée de cet
horizon européen peut-être pas tous mais
la majorité quand même je dirais bah il
faut savoir que voilà l'Occident enfin
la France en tout cas a pris beaucoup de
temps pour nous convaincre que voilà les
Africains comment vous étiez c'était pas
forcément la meilleure façon d'être et
que faire comme la civilisation d'ici
c'était la meilleure façon maintenant
que on en est convaincu et que tout le
monde veut venir la France veut fermer
ses portes mais il faut du temps aussi
pour que les Africains se réapproprient
ce sentiment de voilà on est on est très
bien comme on est parce que il y a il y
a un double sentiment quelque part il y
a oui le blanc il est un peu c'est
commeah il est pas supérieur mais voilà
tout ce qu'il fait c'est ça mystifie on
a envie d'aller voir on a envie d'être
comme le blanc parce que voilà il y a eu
on a pris beaucoup de temps pour ça BR
voilà puis il y a l'autre sentiment
aussi de de oui le blanc c'est un peu
Babylone nous on est un peu supérieur
parce qu'on est les gentils et puis eu
sont méchant enfin c'est c'est un peu
compliqué mais la fascination du blanc
et la fascination de l'Occident c'est
une réalité ça encore dans la tête des
jeunes c'est sûr hein Pier on parle de
des Africains qui partent c'est vrai que
c'est un phénomène spectaculaire et
c'est celui c'est l'image que nous
renvoie un certain nombre de de de
reportages
dramatiques faut par AI AF cet été hein
3 morts au large de l' je pense qu'il
faut aussi parler des des des Africains
qui qui dominent le CDE parle de Brain
gain de gain de l'immigration et pas
seulement de l'exode des cerau g cerau
exactementropolitain donc je veux dire
dès lors que les conditions politiques
économiques sont sont requises on
assiste à des phénomènes de retour qui
sont des éléments de de développement
pas seulement parce qu'il ramènne des
capitaux mais aussi parce qu'il ramène
un apprentissage une connaissance il y a
des il y a des pays où c'est
relativement spectaculaire j'ai
travaillé pendant longtemps au Ghana
donc pays juste en dessous du Burkina
Faso là vous avez des phénomènes de
retour et de et de créateurs
d'entrepreneurs de profession libérale
qui prennent leur part là en terme de
développement ça aussi c'est un moteur
de développement voilà et qui sont
constitutifs de ce qu'on appelait tout à
l'heure la classe moyenne mais la classe
moyenne haute celle qui n'est pas menacé
parce que par des retournements de
conjoncture et il constitu
incontestablement à condition qu'il ne
soit pas complètement pillé dès qu'il
débarque à l'aéroport de leur modeste
épargne et qu'on leur donne
l'opportunité de pouvoir se déployer ça
constitue incontestablement des des des
acteurs du développement futur pour
l'Afrique est-ce qu'on peut imaginer
est-ce que l'Afrique a les moyens de
nourrir tous ses enfants vous avez dit
tout à l'heure 2 milliards d' non il y a
c'est voilà c'est c'est le le problème
mais il y a beaucoup de terres en
Afrique qui sont pas encore exploité en
TER AG comme on dit toujours la
transition démographique vous avez toute
la zone sahello-saliienne sarienne où
vous avez des pays comme le Mali le
Niger vous avez se enfants par femme
pays comme le Niger ils vont passer de
18 millions à 50 millions d'habitants
mais bon quelque part il faut arrêter
aussi on est trop dans un un aspect de
oh là là on dire on va voir c'est
l'impression qu'il va y avoir un
milliard d'immigrés mais non je veux
dire le problème de l'Afrique ce que
j'ai dit je POS la questionir si
l'Afrique peut nourrir si elle a les
moyen de nourrir tous ses enfant non
enfin elle aurait s'il y avait une s'il
y avait une juste redistribution des
terres si vous aviez tout le pétrole du
Sud du Nigéria qui qui avait depuis des
années qui avait pas laissé tout le nord
du Nigéria en des erances bien sûr que
sa chose s'il y avait une redistribution
si vous avez le nord de la Centrafrique
où où où il y avait eu vraiment une
redistribution le nord du Mali la même
chose donc si vous aviez une juste
redistribution son ensemble du pays bien
sûr mais on est dans un dans un monde
profondément inégalitaire vous avons
encore une extrême pauvreté et bon ça va
pas changer demain mais encore une fois
ça va être le continent vraiment des
paradoxes il va falloir à chaque fois on
ne plus parler d'Afrique dire qu'est-ce
qui va se passer au Burkina Faso moi ce
que j'ai retenu là cette femme je trouve
que de en fait vous avez fait votre film
avant la chute de bless qu' pas aé mais
dans sa voix dans sa parole on sentait
déjà le M la colère le mouvement citoyen
le mouvement citoyen on est jeune on
doit se prendre en main c'est plus la
faute des blancs et cetera c'est nous
qui allons faire la révolution et c'est
ce qui c'est ce qui s'est passé au
Burkina ça va sen parler de printemps
africain dans les autres pays il y a un
mimétisme en Afrique vous avez les
jeunes qui vont forcément se prendre en
main c'est des
pays mais bien sûr mais ce continent ce
continent vous avez au Sénégal il y
avait eu un mouvement il y en a Mar le
président abdouah wad qui voulait se
maintenir au pouvoir est parti pas du
tout par l'opposition traditionnelle
mais par ce mouvement il y en a marre au
Burkina Faso c'était le le balai citoyen
et il y aura d'autres balais ailleurs
sur ce continent et vous allez avoir
vraiment des profonds bouleversements
qui vont être très difficiles à
comprendre de l'extérieur parce que ils
vont dire soit il a ceux qui disent oui
c'est toujours le bordel et tout mais
ils se rendent pas compte de ce
continent ils se rendent pas compte des
distances quand on leur dit par exemple
que le rien que le centraafrique c'est
une fois et demi la France vous AZ des
distances absolument gigantesques donc
je veux dire c'est il se passera des
choses horribles à certains endroits et
puis il y aura une urbanisation
accélérée avec des des encore une fois
des gens vous allez avoir les plus beaux
hôtels les plus belles voitures les plus
beaux trucs qui se vendront en Afrique
et on parle de la Chine mais on a pas
parler de l'Inde du Brésil des Turcs je
connais un un chef d'entreprise qui m'a
dit on était sidéré on arrivé à Abidjan
qui était toujours estimé que la Côte
d'Ivoire était le village gaulois il y
avait un Calico énorme bienvenue au
patronat turc parce qu'il avaent oublié
de l'enlever il les patronat turc ils
sont extrêmement important et mobilisé
donc il faut il faut au niveau français
sortir aussi de ce cette on dit toujours
la France Afrique mais il y a bien sûr
une Afrique à France avec des chefs
d'État et et des africains qui ont le
monde entier qui sont comme
interlocuteurs oui mais j'entends bien
que les Français ont un peu perd du pied
he sur ce TER rapport par des
entreprises oui même des entreprises de
quoi rêvent les les burkinaba par
exemple d'une démocratie à la française
ça a un sens ou c'est pas le sujet pas
du tout d'une démocratie à la française
ils le disent d'ailleurs dans les grains
de thé ils disent bon d'abord dans les
grains ils disent la démocratie c'est le
démon à craché parce que qu'est-ce qu'on
sait de la démocratie au Burkina
finalement quand on a le même président
pendant 27 ans qui fait qu de la
dictature qui construit Waga 2000 je
sais pas vous qui avez fait un peu le
Burkina si vous avez vu Waga 2000 c'est
quand même voilà quoi qu'est-ce que
c'est palais c'est une sorte de greffe
occidentale de maisons mais de où on a
mis des millions et des millions et puis
juste à côté vous traversez la route il
y a des gens qui qui ont pas à manger
quoi donc ce qu'on sait de la démocratie
finalement c'est ça c'est c'est les 27
ans de pouvoirs de blise cétait pas une
démocratie ben non mais non mais c'est
formellement
ça c'est ce qu'on en disait oui c'est
venu après une révolution et ça
s'appelait la démocratie il a toujours
dit que cétait de la démocratie mais on
est d'accord que ça n'était pas mais le
citoyen lambda burkinabé qui n'est pas
sorti qui n'a pas d'élément de
comparaison c'est ça la démocratie pour
lui donc il n'en veut pas et puis de
toute façon on ne peut pas copier le le
modèle occidental chez nous parce que
c'est pas les mêmes réalités tout
simplement bah vous prenez par exemple
la sécurité sociale ici on a mis une
sécurité sociale chez nous sur le modèle
d'ici alors que ici bon ben la famille
c'est papa c'est maman c'est les enfants
chez moi la famille comme je disais elle
est manche longue il y a les enfants il
y a les neveux il y a les cousins il y a
l'enfant du voisin l'enfant du voisin
vient te voir parce qu'il est mal
rentrer sur une carte de sécure il y a
trop de monde pour rentrer sur une carte
de sécure faut faut créer un modèle qui
prend en compte ces spécificités qui
sont les nôtres tout simplement sinon ça
ne marche pas mais il y a aujourd'hui
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure des
diplômés ou des gens qui reviennent de
de l'étranger qui reviennent avec des
capacités du talent et de la capacité de
création c'est peut-être ça qui est en
train de se faire pour l'Afrique qui
arrive Les Afriques si vous préférez on
peut considérer justement qu'il y a
quelque chose qui se met en place mais à
condition encore une fois de ne pas
avoir des blaz comparus qui conçoivent
voilà l'état comme parce que Blaise il
gérait son son gouvernement son pays
comme sa famille quoi c'est-à-dire que
c'est il se prenait pour un Alassan
c'est il redistribue mais entre lui ses
frères et puis c'est c'est ses sœurs et
c'est tout quoi j'ai compris la
confiscation d'une certaine manière des
ressources pour revenir à la question
que vous posiez tout à l'heure est-ce
que l'Afrique peut se nourrir elle
pourrait parce qu'en fait on a
aujourd'hui une conjonction de facteurs
qui fait que il y a plus de marge de
manœuvre qui en a jamais eu dans les
économies africaines pour opérer cette
transformation économique et sociale
d'abord parce que les ratios de
dépendance c'estàdire le nombre de de
jeunes et de vieux qui dépendent des
actifs sont en train de s'améliorer
considérablement c'était presque un sur
un à la fin du siècle passé aujourd'hui
ça se réduit considérablement il y a
plus d'actifs qui peuvent nourir moins
de voilà de dépendants d'inactifs on a
également des ressources naturelles on
parlait d'agriculture qui sont
contrairement à ce que beaucoup de gens
pensent largement sous-exploité d'abord
parce qu'elles sont elles sont beaucoup
moins connu que dans le reste du monde
là où en Afrique on investit à peu près
5 dollars par kilomèt carré pour juste
répertorier les ressources naturelles
minéral par exemple sur le sous-sol dans
les autres pays en Amérique Latine ou
les pays de l'OCDE on dépense 65 dollars
par kilomè carré donc ces ressources
sont largement sous inexplloitées et en
plus on a aujourd'hui des cours de
matières premières qui bon même si Stas
vont rester relativement haut et qui
potentiellement peuv générer les revenus
dont on a besoin pour investir dans les
services publics de qualité dans la
santé dans l'éducation tout là donc tout
est là toute la question c'est de savoir
est-ce que les les les la façon dont les
sociétés africaines s'organisent les
gens qui sont au pouvoir vont avoir les
incitations pour promouvoir avec ces
toutes ces opportunités une vraie
transformation qui se traduisent
notamment par la création d'emploi parce
que c'est vraiment de ça qu'on a besoin
pour que les jeunes et ces opportunités
qu'on voit dans le dans le reportage ils
cherchent absolument et qui sur lesquels
leur rêve bute en fait merci à tous les
cas d'avoir participé à ce débat c'était
passionnant aussi passionnant que votre
film je vous remercie encore une fois
pour ce film vous pouvez continuer à
commenter cette émission sur le mail de
de l'émission qui s'affiche comme
toujours en dessous de moi sur votre
écran la semaine prochaine claire Barsac
retourne à eninbaaumont 1 an après la
conquête de la ville par le Front
national à très vite sur public
[Musique]
sénna